today on the Matt Walsh show government
officials are justifying their draconian
lockdown measures by saying life is
precious and it's all worth it if it
saves one life that sort of thing but
many of these officials are Democrats
and therefore pro-abortion extremely
pro-abortion in some cases and so there
seems to be a little bit of a disconnect
here and we're gonna talk about that
also five headlines including the
official jobless numbers for last week
are out and they are historically bad
which which actually is somewhat of an
understatement so we'll discuss that
plus our daily cancellation and an email
from somebody who wants to tell me why
I'm wrong about the argument that I laid
out on the show yesterday so we'll talk
about all of that coming up and I hope
that quarantine is treating you well so
far this is a very so very weird time
very strange time I don't know if we
it's easy to lose sight of just how
strange it is that we're all locked down
three
I think last I saw it's half of the
world's population I think three billion
people are on some kind of lockdown and
I I don't know it you get used to it but
if I had told you six months ago that
this is what we'd be doing in March you
wouldn't believed it I think our
capacity as human beings for getting
used to things is can be good but
there's also a downside I was saying
yesterday on the all-access live show
that I did that you know I think if
aliens were to land on Earth from
another galaxy and start assimilating
into the population we would all be used
to it and bored with it within about
four or five days there would be maybe
one or two days of oh my god aliens are
here and then really quickly it's we're
bored it's just well it's just how it is
that's what life is I wonder if the same
thing is happening with these quarantine
measures and it shouldn't happen I don't
think we want to get used to it now
speaking of the quarantines Governor
Andrew Cuomo of New York has said and
repeatedly returned to the theme as I've
talked about here that all of the lock
downs and the quarantines in his state
will be worth it if it saves just one
life
that's what's he said in other
democratic governors and and
mayors have made similar statements the
mayor of Los Angeles said life is
precious that's why we're doing this
couple nights ago Joe Biden tweeted in
an apparent response to Trump who
obviously has expressed his desire to
open things up again sooner rather than
later said that quote no one is
expendable and no life is worth losing
to add one more point to the Dow now the
first problem with these comments is
that they are manifestly absurd
obviously it would not be worth it to
collapse the economy to save one life
consigning millions to destitution to
save one person would would not be a
fair trade and while it is true that
nobody is expendable as an individual
it's not true that no life is worth
losing in order to salvage the economy
Biden of course is trying to turn the
economic concerns of millions of
Americans into a quibble over points on
the stock market index but he knows
better he well knows just like everybody
else who's pulling this trick of saying
if you're concerned about the economy
you're putting money over people all you
care about is your portfolio and so on
they all know better what's at stake
here is not merely the stock market but
the livelihoods of countless Americans
and we'll talk about this in the news
portion of the of the show the headline
segment but there were over three
million jobless claims last week and
that's only the beginning of it that
only scratches the surface of how bad
things are three million that's not
about points on the Dow okay those are
people those are people's livelihoods so
when we talk about the jobless problem
we're talking about a problem for people
a serious problem not a small problem
this isn't something superficial so what
he's really arguing Biden that is is
that it cannot be it cannot be worth it
for any individual life to be lost in
order to preserve the livelihoods of
many millions and that's simply
ridiculous as we've talked about I
talked about on the show yesterday we
all believe that 35,000 dead on our
roadways every year is a price worth
paying so that we can drive around and
get from point A to point B quicker and
that is a bargain that's a calculation a
deal that we've all made we've all
signed on to it if you hadn't signed on
to it if you haven't signed on to it
then you'd be out there advocating for
the abolition of all of all automobiles
but you're not advocating that and so
what you're saying is okay 35,000 people
32 35,000 people are going to die in
America on the roadways every year that
we allow people to drive but I'm I'm I
don't like it I'm a I'm sad about the
people who died but I'm okay with that
deal so that I can get to the grocery
store faster that's the calculation
you're making so the idea that even one
dead person is not worth it to preserve
the entire economy when we think that
35,000 dead people a year are worth it
just to preserve our ability to drive is
nonsensical we'll talk about more of
this in just a moment but you know I
want to tell you a quick word about
expressvpn it's it's easy to go kind of
stir crazy when you're stuck inside and
you know you spend a lot more time
online and and and I think that's all
the more reason why a VPN might be a
good idea I think we all I don't know if
we if we did does your smartphone give
you an update on how much screen time I
don't remember putting that setting onto
my phone but it's there and so once a
week it'll tell me how much screen time
I've had over the past week and I feel
like my phone is now shaming me at this
point because it's it's a whole lot of
screen time when you're stuck inside
let's be honest did you know that your
internet service provider like Comcast
or Verizon knows every single website
you visit and what's worse is they can
sell this information to ad companies
and tech giant's who will use your data
to target you expressvpn puts a stop to
this it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
cannot be seen by anyone expressvpn
works on everything phones laptops even
routers so everyone who shares your
Wi-Fi can still be protected even if
they don't have expressvpn the best part
is
using expressvpn is as easy as closing
the bathroom door to give yourself a
little privacy it's that easy call so
here's the thing if you're like me and
you believe that your online activity is
your business not anybody else's then
secure yourself by visiting expressvpn
dot-com slash Walsh today use my
exclusive link that's expr e SS VPN comm
slash walsh and you can get an extra
three months free if you do that right
now that's expressvpn comm slash walsh
now so all these statements from Cuomo
Biden etc etc about no worth life is
worth losing and so on we could possibly
take it in a more generous light we
could say perhaps they aren't speaking
literally and and what they really mean
is simply that life is enormous ly
precious and great sacrifices sometimes
necessary in order to preserve it maybe
that's what they're saying well I would
suggest in that case first of all that
now is not the time for vague hyperbole
and platitudes from our leaders and if
they mean life is enormous ly precious
and great sacrifices sometimes necessary
to preserve it then they should just say
that they should say that but more to
the point we already know that these
people do not actually view human life
that way they don't think that human
life is in and of itself precious we
know they don't think that Governor
Cuomo just last year signed a bill into
law that legalized abortion through
every stage of pregnancy way into
viability all the way up to birth with
the supposed stipulation that only if
the mother's health is in jeopardy well
the problem there is that health can be
anything emotional health financial
health psychological health so what that
means is you can get an abortion for any
reason effectively in New York up until
birth
Governor Cuomo signed that into law
thousands and thousands of babies are
killed in New York every year yet Cuomo
hat believes in this slaughter has
helped to facilitate it
the murder of again thousands of fully
developed and viable infants in the womb
this is Biden's view also he's in favor
of this it's a it's a somewhat recently
adopted view but that's his view so it's
clear they don't think that life is
precious they don't believe that heaven
and earth should be moved to save one
life or even a million lives million
lives are taken every year on average by
abortion clinics they don't want to do
anything to stop that in fact they want
to increase it they want to encourage it
they do in fact believe that some life
is expendable
that's what they believe I don't believe
that I would never describe life as
expendable even if I do believe that
there are risks that have to be taken in
order to for a society to function and
you have you have to accept the fact
that people are going to die that's part
that's not just about society that's
part of being mortals so I believe that
yes but I would never say that life is
expendable or worthless that's what
Democrats believe that's not my it's not
a straw man that's that's not my
characterization of it the babies in the
womb that is human life there's no doubt
about that especially as you get into
the later stages during viability now I
would say it's human life or the whole
way through
but whatever obfuscation you try to use
for the very early stages that's not
available to you when you get later on
and you have a viable physically
developed infant okay clearly Eve even
someone who tries to create grey areas
in the womb even they can't do that for
the later stages yet Governor Cuomo says
yeah you can kill a child at that point
that life has no worth has no moral
value it is expendable in fact it has
negative value not just no value
negative value because according to
their ideology the destruct
of innocent life can sometimes be a
positive good and cause for celebration
now I don't suggest that Cuomo Biden or
any of the rest of them are insincere in
their concern for the mostly elderly
people who are being killed by the
coronavirus I'm not saying that I'm sure
they do find the death toll quite
troubling I'm sure they do
want to prevent people from dying just
as any rational person would but they
are plainly insincere in their concern
for human life generally that part is
insincere so we cannot take their
destroy the economy to save one life
arguments literally because the literal
interpretation is insane and we can't
even take the arguments broadly and non
literally because the broad and non
literal interpretation conflicts with
their platforms and their policies so we
are left then with no way to take these
statements except as lies plain and
simple and that's what it is and it
quite a problem because when you've got
leaders in government taking these
historic dramatic steps locking down the
entire economy taking people's jobs from
them their livelihood and then you can't
trust or believe the reasons they give
well well that that becomes a recipe for
disaster on many different fronts and
that's what we're facing here now let's
go on to your five headlines the US
Department of Labor report I just
mentioned this but I think we need to
get a little bit deeper into it
u.s. part of Labor reports that more
than 3.2 million Americans filed for
unemployment last week across the
country that's 3.2 million okay now let
me let me put these numbers into
perspective 3.2 million is about 1% of
the nation's population 1 percent of the
nation becoming what unemployed in 1
week is very very high and those who are
in favor of locking down the whole
economy and definitely they have to
agree that 1% is high because that's
what they've been telling us the death
rate is for the coronavirus they may in
fact be much lower than that but they
say 1% they tell us it's very high I
agree that you know in that context 1%
is high in in this context 1% is really
high also the previous record for
unemployment in one week going all the
way back to 1982 was 695 thousand now if
you're wondering the population was 230
million back then so that was about half
of a percent of the population which
means in raw numbers our unemployment
claims last week were 5 times higher 5
times higher than the previous historic
high and in terms of the other percent
of the population it was still twice as
high last week as has ever been
recorded before so no matter how you
look at it this is utterly unprecedent
unlike anything our country is a scene
in history the coronavirus is not and
will not be the worst epidemic this
country has ever experienced however bad
it is or will be it's not going to be
that bad when I say not that bad I mean
it's not I don't mean it's not gonna be
that bad I mean it's not gonna be as bad
as the worst we've seen I think that
much is clear by now but our response to
it may well bring about the worst
economic crash we've ever seen so does
that make sense is that proportionate is
that balanced in your mind keep
something else in mind the real number
of jobless people right now or people
made jobless last week is way way way
higher than 3.2 million we don't know
exactly how high it is but we have to
remember that many types of workers
don't qualify for unemployment plus
there are going to be others who do
qualify but don't know they do
we're haven't filed and then there are
others who tried to file and couldn't
because unemployment websites across the
country are crashing and the the numbers
that people are calling are jammed up
with all without with everybody else
calling at the same time so when you add
all them into it and then you also add
in the number of people who've been made
jobless seds this past Sunday because
we're talking about last week's numbers
how many in the last two weeks how many
actual people have been made jobless you
want to talk about exponential it is
exponentially higher than 3.2 million
just want to take a quick second to tell
you about a new book that's out listen
we're all quarantine we're locked down
and if you don't want to spend all of
your time watching TV or just staring at
a blank wall
you know I've resorted to that a few
times a great way to kill some time is
to have a very good book and fortunately
I've got one I could tell you about Joel
C Rosenberg is a New York Times
bestselling author who draws from
extensive research and real-life
meetings with world leaders for his
fact-based
fiction and his books have been read and
enjoyed by lots of high-ranking people
including vice president pence and
others Joel's new novel The Jerusalem
assassin centers around a fictional
American president who's ready to roll
out a Middle East peace plan as the time
draws near to announce the peace plan in
Jerusalem
high-ranking American officials begin to
be assassinated one by one CIA operative
Marcus ryegrass has spent his career
studying killers and now he has to think
like one to stop a deadly threat this is
a fast-paced book edge-of-your-seat
thriller kind of book and it it although
a lot of the subject matter is very very
related to the real world and serious it
does take you out of everything we're
dealing with now a little bit and
absorbs you in a fascinating story and
then you avoid the unbearable boredom
and we know that boredom is can be
deadly boredom is the devil's playground
isn't that the saying something like
that the hard covered a book versions of
the Jerusalem assassin by Joel see
rosenburg are available at your favorite
retailers website through the end of
March my listeners can get a hardcover
copy of the Jerusalem assassin for an
additional 10% off at Tyndale comm tyn
da le comet's Tyndale comm by entering
Walsh at checkout
Tyn da le com promo code Walsh for an
additional 10% off of the hardcover book
number 2 the Senate's passed its two
trillion dollar stimulus package overall
as Trump's Trump's economic advisors
tell us the total cost of the
government's relief efforts will be
closer to six trillion dollars now I've
already complained about the stimulus
package many times I think you know you
know my complacent I gotta reiterate all
of them I will just emphasize that this
deal that gives 1200 bucks to some
Americans with this deal lots of people
who need the money won't get it lots of
people who don't need it will get it and
lots of people who need it and do get it
aren't getting nearly enough and so I'm
not sure
this accomplishes I have been in favor
of I what I what I proposed and
advocated is you give give money to
everybody give money to everybody and
then people who get it and don't need it
can donate it to someone else who does
need it more than they do
and that way communities can also take
part it's it's sort of a collective
effort between government and
communities and people but what they're
doing here is sort of the worst of all
worlds where they're choosing basically
arbitrarily a certain segment of the
population to give money to and giving
it to everybody in that segment and
nobody else outside of it so that
there's not for my idea of communities
helping each other and donating the
money and kind of there's not enough of
it for that to work now now we're just
we're gonna exclude some people and
include everybody over here which as I
as I have explained you know that this
means if the cutoff is 75 thousand for
an individual and then it starts
dwindling from there and at 99,000 its
cutoff for ninety eight thousand I think
it's it's a it's go 99 thousand right
it's it cut it cuts off completely well
that means you know there are gonna be
plenty of people who make sixty or
seventy thousand a year
single individuals and still have a job
right now working from home still have
an income don't need the money they
haven't lost any money and so we're
gonna send them a check anyway meanwhile
you're gonna have a lot of people who
made over ninety nine thousand last year
but maybe are but are out of work right
now and maybe their business has already
collapsed and now they're not getting
anything
maybe they clearly need it more than the
person who's making an income they get
nothing the person have you it's it
doesn't I'm sorry it doesn't make any
sense and then yes there will be some
people's as the government's rolling the
dice and hoping that kind of just really
just throwing darts and hoping that a
few of them hit the right people well
yeah they a few of them will but those
people 1,200 bucks if you're out of work
now you've been out of work for two
weeks you're probably gonna be out of
work for another who knows how long what
does 1200 dollars gonna do for you it
maybe it'll pay the rent depending on
where you live it's not gonna buy food
you're gonna have to choose buy food pay
the rent you know if somebody has living
expenses what's the what's the point of
spending trillions of dollars to send to
some people enough money to pay half of
their living expenses for one month I
know you might say it's better than
nothing but is it it's it's actually I'm
not even sure that it is and is it worth
the trillions of dollars that we're
spending it to me it just seems like a
waste you might as well burn the money
might as well just take trillions of
dollars and just burn it if this is how
we're gonna spend it number three one of
the men behind the doomsday Imperial
College projections the the one that
scared governments across the world into
putting three billion people under
lockdown has now suddenly adopted a more
optimistic view of things reading now
from the New Scientist says the UK
should now be able to cope with the
spread of Cova 19 virus according to one
of the epidemiologist advising the
government Neil Ferguson at Imperial
College London gave evidence today to
the UK's parliamentary Select Committee
on science and technology as part of an
inquiry into the nation's response to
the growing of virus outbreak
he said that expected increases in
national health service capacity and
ongoing restrictions people's movements
make him reasonably confident the Health
Service can cope when the predicted peak
of the epidemic arrives in two or three
weeks UK deaths from the disease are now
unlikely to exceed 20,000 he said and
could be much lower the need for
intensive care beds will give very close
to capacity in some areas but won't be
breached at a national levels at
Ferguson the projections are based on
computer simulations of the virus
spreading which take into account the
properties of the virus the reduced
transmission between people and the
capacity of hospitals particularly
intensive care units so he has he's one
of the guys that effectively said this
could be a world destroying event and it
was the in these projections from the
Imperial College of College of London
are largely why we're seeing everything
we're seeing now in terms of the
government's response and now he said
that might not be that bad
and I know that when it comes to
projecting what a virus is going to do
nobody can be a hundred percent right
you can't look into the future but this
also isn't something we can wave off and
say value was wrong yeah oh yeah okay he
was he was a little off on that when
you're making projections that caused
government's to shut down and millions
to be left destitute this isn't just a
my bad type of thing meanwhile dr. Burks
during a press conference yesterday had
some words about media outlets that are
hyping up Armageddon she's she's telling
us to calm down a little
not that it isn't serious but she has
tried to put things in perspective so
what's this the numbers that have been
put out there are actually very
frightening to people but I can tell you
if you go back and look at Wuhan and who
Bay and all of these provinces when they
talk about 60,000 people being infected
even if you said oh right well there's
asymptomatic sand all of that so you get
to 600,000 people out of 80 million that
is nowhere close to the numbers that you
see people putting out there I think it
is frightened the American people I
think on a freely on a model that you
just run full-out you can get to those
numbers if you have zero controls and
you do nothing and we know that every
American is doing something some some
much-needed sanity I think there by the
way before we go on if you hadn't had a
chance to watch some of our new content
called all-access live you should head
over to Daley wire comm check it out
Jeremy boring and ben shapiro kicked it
off last week we'd be doing live streams
every single day i did one yesterday and
i think it's a lot of fun it's a more
relaxed environment we're just sort of
having a conversation qaq a night i
would even call it a Q&A it's not that
official or structured it's really just
a back and forth dialogue which i have
really enjoyed and the thing is
originally the plan was to roll this out
I don't know weeks from now but we've
rolled it out early
and this was also intended for our all
access members but during the national
emergency and quarantines while people
are isolated we've opened it up to all
of our members and and also as I said
accelerated the launch so if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern tonight 5 p.m.
Pacific then head over and join us on
all access live it's a lot of fun and I
hope you'll be there where are we number
4 Oh
important news here Pete Buddha judge
according to this photo
take a look is now growing a beard
here's what I don't get
and yeah if he stops there then we can't
call that a beard but it looks at if
he's if he's on his way to a beard then
we could say he's growing a beard but
even here's what I don't get well why do
these guys always wait until they lose
to grow the beard Buddha judge did it
I think O'Rourke did it right Ted Cruz
in the most prominent example Ted Cruz
yeah every man can improve his
appearance by growing a beard I think
for Ted Cruz the speaking of exponential
the improvement was was exponential and
yet he waited until you know he lost the
presidential primary to grow folk road I
don't get it this idea that if you're
running for president you have to be
baby-faced clean-shaven like some kind
of freak I don't understand that you
know we have not had as I've been
screaming about for years we have not
had a president with facial hair in over
a century and look at what's happening
to America right now you think this is a
coincidence think about this think about
the entire 20th century how horrific
that was in many ways and now we've got
lock downs of pandemic you think it's a
coincidence I don't think so
imagine if we've had bearded presidents
this whole time
imagine how much different things would
be bearded men obviously are
better-looking smarter better leaders
stronger and yet
we say for the most important job in the
world for some reason this unofficial
rule if you're running you can't have a
beard makes no sense to me number five
the mayor of Chicago is now warning
residents of the city that they must not
spend too much time outside even if
they're well outside out out in the open
you can't be outside for too long
reading from CBS Chicago visibly
frustrated with reports of gatherings
throughout Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot
delivered a stern warning to those who
continue to get together during The Cove
in nineteen pandemic we will shut it
down and you may be arrested
Lightfoot said stay at home only go out
for essentials you have to readjust your
thinking be smart not only will our
police be deployed to shut them down if
you're out if you're not abiding by
these orders we will be forced to shut
down the parks and lakefront situation
is deadly serious and we need you to
take it deadly seriously
Lightfoot added that spending long
periods of time outdoors anywhere is not
allowed and neither is going into closed
spaces like playgrounds you cannot go on
long bike rides playgrounds are shut
down you must abide by the order outside
is for a brief respite not for five K's
I can't emphasize that enough this is
look I can't see this is anything other
than a an absurd power trip from this
mayor now you're telling people how long
they can spend outside you can go
outside for four five and a half minutes
not one minute longer you understand me
Kim iam Haig like how are you gonna
if you're going for a walk outside how
are you gonna catch the virus you take
basic precautions you're going for a
walk you're not you're you're you know
you're not you're not licking the
bending down and licking the sidewalk
you're just going for a walk okay if you
pass by someone you give them a little
bit of space how are you gonna catch it
I'm not saying it's impossible but how
likely is it that a person let's say you
are running a 5k
how are you catching the virus right on
a 5k even if as you're running somebody
coughed directly in your path the
chances of catching it are still pretty
damn low but that's probably not gonna
happen so it's I understand you don't
want large gatherings and in enclosed
spaces that's where you have a lot of
the spreading that goes on but outside
really you can't go for a walk outside
you're gonna shut down the lakefront how
are you gonna do that build a giant wall
now we're finally gonna build the wall
we'll get an armed policeman stationed
there shoot on sight come on like it's
possible to say let's take this
seriously let's take some precautions
without going all the way to this
screaming at people you're gonna have
arrested if they spend too much time
jogging outside it's not a zombie
apocalypse I mean this is what I would
expect if there was an actual zombie
apocalypse
then I would expect stay inside your
house board up the windows do not go
outside for any reason I would expect
that in a zombie a but for this tell me
if
if I'm apparently like if I'm in Chicago
and I just want to sit on my front porch
yeah I'm not allowed to do that tell me
how do I catch the virus sitting on my
front porch tell me how I do if
somebody's walking by the sidewalk and
I'm on my porch and they cough how do I
catch it is is the virus gonna travel in
the air in the open you know 25 meters
to infect me is there any research
suggesting that that is even slightly
likely
now for your daily cancellation we will
once again be canceling the celebrities
the celebrities are up to their tricks
again as we've discussed the celebrity
communities having a very hard time
being locked down not getting attention
not having the paparazzi chasing them
around it's it's really difficult and
they're resorting to these increasingly
desperate measures to get attention
because they need it the way that you
need water or food they need attention
if they don't get it it's a biological
need they will shrivel up like raisins
and die without it so now the
celebrities are in a stunning act of
bravery taking pictures of themselves
without makeup to get attention now the
courage this requires is extraordinary
imagine being an attractive person with
lots of plastic surgery already and then
having the gumption
having a fortitude the vision to take a
picture without 18 pounds of makeup
incredible simply incredible page six
reports they may be used to getting
glammed up for the red carpet but just
like the rest of the world celebrities
are currently staying home and
practicing social distancing during the
corona virus pandemic with no buzzie
premieres or press events on their
calendars for this time for the time
being these stars are skipping makeup in
favor of letting their natural beauty
shine through and they're sharing it all
on social media below see a selection of
stars who are going the barefaced route
then here's a few of the pictures Julia
Roberts Jessica Alba Kaylee Coco cuoco I
don't know who that is Heidi Klum now
what's going on here what does Heidi
Klum doing she appears to be holding a
piece of what does that mulch it's not a
piece of mulch she's holding it's a
piece of mulch that looks like a heart
and she has her eyes closed in peaceful
ecstasy and someone has taken a picture
of her with the sun shining behind her
head almost making a halo effect now is
that what it's like to go for a
walk with a supermodel it might sound
like could be a lot of fun but but but
really is this what happens you're
taking a stroll and then she finds a
piece of mulch that she likes and next
thing you know you're taking ninety
thousand pictures from a hundred
different angles oh my word this mulch
get a picture of me with this mulch you
see this mulch anyway is it but isn't
she wearing makeup looks like she's
wearing makeup I'm no expert but that
appears to be makeup it looks like
something on her lips some kind of
makeup on her lips I don't know any case
still very courageous very brave simply
stunning
I am speechless especially as someone
who you know myself I've gone mostly
without makeup but I still have to put
on a dash of eyeliner a bit of lipstick
some foundation just a little bit a
little bit to get me through I don't
have the courage to do what they're
doing
wow wow what's still canceled okay let's
go to emails I'll read one email and
then we'll have a why why you're wrong
email but first and remember you can
become a daily why I remember and send
emails to the mailbag this is from
father Greg says hey Matt in today's
show you talked about soulmates I
thought it would be an interesting
diversion if I understood you correctly
you rejected the idea of soulmates and
think the concept is dangerous as it
applies if you made the wrong choice and
later meet your soulmate you are
entitled to leave your wife in contrast
you proposed a model of soulmates where
your wife becomes your soulmate when you
make the commitment please correct me if
I miss something Mike what you did not
my question is is the distinction you
laid out exhaustive Aquinas implies this
this distinction is not he argues with
reference to the priesthood that someone
can can discern wrongly in which case
someone could choose the priesthood when
he was called to marriage or vice-versa
Aquinas however goes on to clarify that
when that man is ordained or married his
calling from that point changes this is
due to the call to universal fidelity
could the same logic not exist with
soulmates where a man has a soulmate and
marries the wrong person but the
universal call to fidelity causes his
new wife to become his soulmate I don't
know whether the soul mates exist I just
think was an interesting question well
that's a difference between of course
vocation so you're talking about
vocation
so if someone is called to the religious
life and I do believe that many people
are then that's a vocation and I do
believe there are many people called to
it who don't who do not heed the call
and there were probably some people who
are not called to it and that's obvious
too who are not called to it and yet and
yet become religious and the same thing
could happen with marriage where people
are called to marriage yet they don't
that's their vocation is marriage yet
they don't get married or they do get
married and that wasn't their vocation
and it could happen in careers you know
of course of course
fortunately with careers it's a lot
easier to switch courses midstream you
can't really do that or at least you
shouldn't do it with marriage or
priesthood so that that's vocation I
think that's different from this with
the soulmate thing the idea is if we
believe that our soulmates
what we're saying is that there is one
person one well it's not that you're
called to marriage it's that you're
called to one particular person who's
out there somewhere and that's the
person you're supposed to marry and so I
would I I still would reject that
premise I don't I just don't think it's
true and he wouldn't even I don't even
know exactly what it means what exactly
does that mean
there's someone who God has designed for
you and but he's he's hid that person
out in the world so much so it's like
Where's Waldo right and and you you
could choose the wrong person and now
you're stuck with that person instead so
to me it doesn't make sense it doesn't
seem like a particularly wise way to set
up set things up so I wouldn't I
wouldn't expect that God is all wise and
all-knowing would and and again as you
say what once you become married then
that person is your soulmate so what why
do we need a pre-marriage soulmate so I
would say you know when you meet
somebody if you're single and you meet
someone and you say this person is my
soulmate well they're not they could
become that if you get married but right
now they're not
let's see Arthur says hopefully you'll
read this this this Arthur wants to tell
me why I'm wrong about something he says
there's a distinction I think you might
be missing between shutting things down
for the virus as opposed to cars cars
are voluntary it's true that getting in
a car can kill you but that a risk you
and that's a risk you acknowledge when
you get in a car and start driving it
it's an inherent risk that you know
about and choose to accept they're all
there are alternatives to driving I'm
not saying that it's good I'm saying
that the government's responsibility
isn't to regulate an accepted risk if
iris on the other hand cannot be avoided
reasonably because of how the
transmission works from person to person
that is when the government has a
responsibility to step in and help
people I'm not saying that the
government has picked the best option
when it comes to Cova 19 response but I
am saying that there's a difference
between the two and furthermore
hindsight is 20/20 okay right but III
think again you're kind of missing the
point Arthur I don't I don't think that
this has anything to do with what I'm
talking about
and first of all you say that the
government doesn't have a responsibility
to regulate an accepted risk they do
regulate driving they regulate the hell
out of driving in order to mitigate the
risk yet we still know that there is a
risk and even with all those mitigation
efforts there are going to be thirty to
thirty five thousand people who die on
the roadways and that number is only
going to go up probably as as the
population increases so we know that and
what you're again getting into the
confusion I think you have is you're
talking about the specific differences
between a virus and car accidents and
how one is more dangerous than the other
and one is more avoidable than the other
now you say that there's nothing we can
reasonably do to avoid getting a virus I
disagree with that I think there are a
lot of things we do that's why we're
talking about washing look if you wash
your hands you've already done quite a
lot to avoid getting the virus if you if
you don't touch your face you've done
quite a lot now as you can see when I do
this show I I'm very bad at that part of
it but I do wash my hands a lot so
hopefully it's okay I'm also not leaving
my house so the same time I feel like
maybe touching my face isn't a big deal
either way there's plenty we can do to
avoid getting a virus
but that's all of that is irrelevant how
dangerous it is how much it can be
avoided all of that is that's not the
point my point is simply this to say it
again every year that we allow people to
drive their cars thirty to thirty five
thousand people will die and across the
world it would be a million people where
there abouts
and there will be tens of thousands more
if not hundreds of thousands more I
don't know who are who are seriously
injured named maimed or crippled in car
accidents we know that is the cost of
having our cars and yet nobody says
let's get rid of cars and so what we are
the calculation we have made the bargain
we have made the deal we've made is
those thirty five thousand dead are a
price worth paying so that we can drive
we don't want to put it that way we
don't want to think of it that way we're
not saying that it would be worth it to
actively kill thirty five thousand
people to like appease the gods or
something so that we can drive that's
not the point
okay we're not we're not saying that we
should go out and kill thirty five
thousand people ourselves in order to
drive what we're saying is if people
drive thirty five thousand people are
there abouts will die we don't want them
to but they will and although we're very
sad about that we will accept that side
effect and then we bring
19 discussion and we say okay in order
to preserve our economy we know what
we're willing to accept in order to
preserve our ability to drive what are
we willing to accept in terms of a death
toll in order to preserve our economy
and our way of life and our livelihoods
our cars along with our homes and our
retirement savings and the food in our
fridge and everything else what are we
willing to accept there in terms of risk
in terms of potential death toll it's
got to be way over 35,000 so what is it
I don't know I'm just saying that's the
point that's the ethical question that
we're dealing with alright but thank you
for that email and we will cut it off
there
Thanks I'm ready for watching stay safe
out there
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 the US Senate passes a two trillion
dollar coronavirus relief package after
days of intense debate we will examine
the good the bad and the ugly
then more good news on the scientific
front of the pandemic more fury from the
mainstream media and a major me to
allegation against Joe Biden we will
analyze the evidence and the accuser
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]